super wild card weekend dare i say super
duper wild card weekend what was your
thoughts when you saw what juju smith
schuster had to say
you know
my first thought was that
a he wished that he didn't get asked
that question
b
uh what sort of word salad can i put
together to get out of here to get out
of this uh question and see
he probably just should have said
uh man the browns look great this year
next question
i don't know i
mike i guess it's being 63 years old a
i don't really take what players say in
pregame press conferences unless he were
to say
baker mayfield stinks
and kevin stefanski is a [ __ ] i i you
know i'm i don't i don't really take
much out of that that's a and b
when is the last time ever
that you've heard a player after a game
say you know what i played harder
because juju smith schuster wasn't very
complimentary of us
well it was just a couple weeks ago
peter it was when juju danced on the
logo in cleveland and von bell got a
shot at him and he blasted him
into the next county and said so after
the game so it happens it's real yes it
is
it's real it is from all the guys on the
steelers roster who shouldn't be talking
it's juju
it is real but that was an action that
was not words that was an action the
same thing the cowboys did to tara owens
a generation ago
you know and so i totally understand
that i would have done the same thing if
i were a player
i would have blasted them legally as
hard as i could
but it's it's different when you're just
sitting there hey what do you think of
the browns well the browns are the
browns
it's it's meaningless it's meaningless
anyway
well well
i i i hate the phrase we can agree to
disagree anytime someone says that to me
i say i disagree to disagree because i'm
right there's no disagreement
but let me tell you this and we're going
to talk about all of the playoff games
today
i guarantee you that tom brady
has been using the thing that chase
young said which wasn't really all that
inflammatory but this is a guy who will
use anything
to reach an extra level of frenzy if
need be and of course brady when he had
an opportunity to talk about it
everything's great everything's fine and
he laughs it off i think the fire that
already was burning in his belly has an
extra coal or two on it when something
like that said these are football
players you know because i've seen this
too many times where they try to act
like they don't listen and they act like
they don't care
but the actions that follow the words
tell me that they really do they'd like
us to think they don't whether it's
words from us words from other players
words from fans words from coaches i
think they act like it doesn't matter
because they don't want to dignify the
reality that they actually hear us
because they're here and we're there
but they hear it and they use it
whenever they can and as we learned with
michael jordan from the excellent
documentary that seems like it was a
decade ago when that was unfolding an
episode or two per week they'll make
stuff up if they have to if it gets them
into the mindset where they want to be
you know i guess so i just simply think
that
you know players are going to play in a
game
and they're going to give their maximum
effort and if i had a player on my team
if i coached and i had a player on my
team and look i understand the tom brady
way kevin green was like that a lot god
rest his soul
um
where every time he would look for the
tiniest slight brady does that too
players throughout history have done
that
but
most of the time these tiny slights are
invented crapola
that's i mean if chase young says i want
brady
that doesn't mean
brady stinks it means this is the
highlight of my life i can't wait to
play tom brady give me brady
that's how i take it i don't take it oh
man i can't wait to sack brady six times
because he's an immobile sack of
potatoes
no it means i want to play tom brady
right and brady takes it as brady stinks
that's the point you can take it however
you want to take it and if it helps you
get ready and achieve at a higher level
than you would have so be it now for the
browns
they have far bigger fish
caught on the shores of the cuyahoga
to fry because
they've got a covet 19 outbreak you know
for a week plus the nfl was saying they
don't have an outbreak they don't have
an outbreak it's all community spread at
some point
they had to acknowledge it now is an
outbreak and we're not even 100 sure the
game's going to go forward they've told
us all year they won't play a game if
there is an uncontained outbreak well
based upon the results of the daily
clarence beaks crop report that we hear
about every morning we could be at that
point come sunday for now though what we
know is the browns haven't practiced all
week and they may not practice today and
they may not practice before the game
here's baker mayfield from yesterday
talking about the impact on the browns
of potentially not practicing at all
before they play the steelers on sunday
night
it is what it is there's no excuses but
luckily we just played them last week so
uh it's not like we're practicing a bun
against a bunch of different uh
a whole new defense essentially is what
i'm trying to get at so we have to be
ready for the wrinkles like i said but
luckily we've game plan against these
guys and
everybody's sitting here in the second
week in a row of preparation for the
pittsburgh defense
you can delude yourself into thinking
that if you're baker mayfield and you
have no other alternatives but the
reality is they prepared and played the
steelers jv team on sunday there was no
ben roethlisberger more importantly for
mayfield's purposes peter there was no
tj watt life changes dramatically and
comes at you very fast when tj watt is
in the lineup and tj watt is screaming
around the edge and tj watt is keeping
you from doing the things that make you
a good quarterback like using some
mobility he doesn't have a high degree
of mobility but he has some that's some
mobility
reduces dramatically when tj watt is
chasing him so it's going to be a
different experience for the browns and
mike tomlin and the steelers surely
didn't lay all cards on the table
in a game that for the most part was
meaningless to pittsburgh on sunday
you know what i thought yesterday mike
when i uh when i heard that they were
going through the day and almost
certainly wouldn't practice
and it was going to be their fourth day
out of the facility and all that you
know what i kept thinking
i kept thinking
if you're mike tomlin
you're ben roethlisberger you're the
pittsburgh steelers can you imagine
what will happen
if the nfl says to you uh this game has
now been postponed until tuesday
can you imagine
the fervor in that building and the
anger in that building
that your playoff lives are getting
messed with by this team you know what i
do if i were art rooney i'd call roger
goodell and i'd say look
if you are going to push this game back
we want our next game to be on monday
not on sunday
and in fact
in the department of unintended
consequences
how great would it be and how big would
the number be
pittsburgh at buffalo monday night
football
having
basically having one game saturday to
sunday and a monday night game on
divisional playoff weekend that's where
my mind went yesterday
but
as far as what's going on right now look
all i can think of at this time of year
is when jc tritter of the the nflpa
president and
you know the
center of the cleveland browns
when he put out his little manifesto a
couple of weeks ago and said we don't
want any off season programs anymore
you know
there's something late in the season
that isn't bad
about staying off your feet
and maybe getting on a treadmill to run
for 20 minutes in a day but otherwise
and lifting a couple of weights but
otherwise staying off your feet
resting
and ben roethlisberger did it before the
cincinnati game this year played one of
his best games of the year
so all i'm saying is i'm not sure that
it's the worst thing in the world that
you don't practice
intensively and if you do play if you do
play
kevin stefanski has already sort of
made it happen you know twice this year
on game days he's had walk-throughs when
he's had to get players up and ready to
go so i don't know that's my word salad
of thought about what happened to the
browns
i got a couple of quick reactions and
i'll work backward first one of those
walkthroughs came on the day they lost
to the jets so
you know
second second i don't disagree with jc
tretter's sentiments and there will be a
push by the union although it's part of
collective bargaining and i keep
wondering why does the union keep
pushing this what are they willing to
give up to get it could it be an 18th
game i don't want to open that can of
worms but
if you do have one team shut down and
the other team still practicing
what will that
look like when they play if if it was
both teams shut down like all teams no
off-season program and all teams no
preseason games that levels out the
competitive
balance
when one team isn't practicing and the
other team is
the one team that isn't practicing could
be walking into a buzz saw and lastly
shireen williams and i on pftp earlier
this week were kicking around how the
schedule could adjust if you would move
to tuesday you'd have to let the winter
play the following monday you would
discover plutonium by accident in the
ratings that would come from a monday
night playoff game and the following
weekend i think you'd have to let the
team that wins on monday night play the
conference championship on monday night
and i've been advocating for several
years now instead of back to back sunday
games go sunday night monday night prime
time prime time you got 13 days until
the super bowl no one's at a
disadvantage if you do that and as we've
learned this year these other windows
these other opportunities double header
on monday tuesday night game wednesday
night game i think this gets the
creative juices flowing from the
league's perspective as to ways they can
spread out the cluster of sunday games
and get bigger ratings have more
opportunities for in-game gambling for
people who are focused on one game at a
time
and make a hell of a lot more money at
the end of the day
mike i you know i totally agree with you
i think that if
the ncaa championship game
had not been scheduled for monday night
for a long time you know because
that obviously on january 11
the ncaa championship game was scheduled
and i kept asking in the off season
is there any way
not necessarily going head to head
because you don't want to kill college
football
is there any way you'd play one of those
six games at five o'clock in the
afternoon on monday you'd get a gigantic
crowd and i would bet i bet
that especially given the state of
america today
where so many people at five o'clock in
the afternoon on monday
are not in an office
um
i think the i think the number would be
much larger than it would be uh saturday
at 1 pm
uh so but be that as it may be that as
it may i really think that the nfl
next year is gonna try to do
one of these six games in a prime time
window
uh hopefully on monday after the
you know the weekend where there would
be five games we'll see what happens but
to me
i'm not saying the saturday 1pm window
is a throwaway
but i'm saying you can get a much bigger
audience playing it at a different time
one more point on this game before we
move on to the second game to be played
on saturday uh actually well this that's
the sunday night game but i'm i'm i'm so
used to going through these games
sequentially i i got a little twisted
the game we're talking about obviously
the last game of the weekend we are
going to see
through the absence of kevin stefanski
what a coach is truly worth on game day
because with stefanski not there mike
prefer the special teams coordinator
will be the head coach alex van pelt
will call the plays and we will get an
opportunity even though it's going to be
a one game sample size to see what a
head coach means or doesn't mean in a
playoff setting and i think
unfortunately for the browns we're going
to find out that your head coach means a
hell of a lot on game day
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports